PROFESSOR: So in
this example, we
want to hit an apple hanging
from a tree with a projectile.
And the main point
of the problem
is to figure out at
what angle to the ground
should we aim our projectile
when we fire it off
in order to hit the apple.
And in this example,
we're assuming
that the apple drops from
the tree at the same instant
that we fire the projectile.
So in this drawing, let's just
put some dimensions in here,
we'll assume that
the apple starts out
at a height, h,
above the ground.
That the horizontal
distance from where
the projectile starts to
the apple is a distance, d.
That the projectile starts at a
distance, s, above the ground.
And that we fire the projectile
off with an initial velocity,
v0, at an angle theta, sorry,
theta not, with respect
to the horizontal.
And let's define our origin to
be right here on the ground,
directly below where
the projectile begins.
We need to define our
coordinate system,
so the i-hat direction will
be horizontally to the right,
and the j-hat direction
will be vertically upwards
with an origin at this point.
So the question that
we have is, what
should our angle,
theta0 b, in order
to hit the apple,
which starts falling
from the tree at
the same instant
that we fire our
projectile, and we
want to hit the apple
before it hits the ground.
OK so to work this out,
we need to consider
the kinematics of two separate
objects, our projectile
and the apple.
So let's begin with the apple.
So for our apple, the apple
drops vertically straight
downwards, so its horizontal
position throughout its motion
is just unchanged.
So the x-coordinate of the
apple as a function of time
is just d, it's just a constant.
It's y-coordinate, it
starts out at a height, h,
and then it drops due to
the acceleration of gravity,
and so that's given by
minus 1/2 gt-squared.
It's a minus because it's
falling in the minus j-hat
direction.
Now for our projectile,
let's call it a bullet.
For our bullet, the
x-coordinate of the bullet,
it starts out at the
origin, at x equals zero.
And its initial motion, it
has an initial velocity, v0,
in this direction.
The horizontal
component of that is
v0 times the cosine of theta0.
And so it's displacement
of time t is v0 t times
the cosine of theta 0.
And there's no
horizontal acceleration,
so that completes
our x-coordinate
as a function of time.
For our y-coordinate,
we start out
at a height, s,
above the ground.
There is the change
in the y-coordinate
due to the initial velocity,
which has component v0 sine
theta0, so that's plus
v0 t sine theta 0.
And there's also a
vertical acceleration
due to gravity, which gives
us minus 1/2 gt-squared.
OK so that's the kinematics
of the apple and the bullet.
Now for there to be a hit
at time t equals capital-t,
the coordinates of the
apple and the bullet
have to be the same at
that collision time.
So for a hit at t
equals big T, we
require that the x-coordinate
of the bullet at time big T
is the same as the
x-coordinate of the apple.
And likewise, that the
y-coordinate of the bullet
is equal to the
y-coordinate of the apple.
OK so let's look at
each of these in turn.
For our x-coordinate, the
x-coordinate of the bullet
is v0 capital-T times
the cosine of theta 0.
And that has to be equal
to the x coordinate
of the apple, which is just d.
So notice that I can solve this
for the time of the collision,
capital-t, and that's
just d minus v0 times
the cosine of theta 0.
Now for our y-coordinate, the
y-coordinate of the bullet
is s plus v0 capital-T
time is the sine of theta
not minus 1/2 gt
squared and that's
equal to the y-coordinate
of the apple, which
is h minus 1/2 gt squared.
All right, now I
can rearrange that.
Notice that I have a minus
1/2 gt squared on both sides,
so those cancel out.
I can rearrange that to write
v0 times capital-T times
the sine of theta 0
is equal to h minus s,
so that the sine of theta 0
is equal to h minus s over v0
capital T. But remember we
solved for capital-T here,
so I can substitute that in.
So that gives me h minus
s over v0 times 1 over t,
which is v0 cosine
theta 0 over d.
And so I can rewrite that
as h minus s over d times
to cosine of theta 0.
So rewriting that, I have
on the left hand side,
sine of theta 0 over
cosine of theta 0
is equal to h minus s over d.
And notice on the left
hand side, sine over cosine
is just tangent, so this is
just the tangent of theta 0.
Now think about what that means.
If I draw a right triangle
where this is theta 0,
then this is h minus
s and this is d.
And so this is the same
geometry we have here,
if we drew the
triangle like this.
So theta 0 is just the angle
to the location of the apple
just before it drops.
So what this
calculation tells us
is that the correct thing to
do if we want to hit the apple,
if we know the apple is going
to drop at the same instant
that we fire, then we
should aim at the location
that the apple is
at that instant.
We shouldn't try and lead
the apple and fire below it
or fire above it, we should
aimed directly at the apple.
And what the
kinematics shows us is
that both the
bullet and the apple
fall vertically down
at the same rate.
And so that will
give us a collision.
Now it's worth thinking
about two different cases,
which I'm not going
to solve for you here.
The first is, what if
the apple didn't drop?
Suppose the apple just stayed
in the tree and I fired.
If I aimed directly at the
apple and the apple didn't drop,
then I would miss the apple,
because the bullet would
drop as it went across
this distance, d.
Now of course if the
apple were big enough,
or if the bullet were
flying fast enough,
if v 0 was fast
enough, then it might
be that the amount
of the bullet dropped
wouldn't be bigger than
the thickness of the apple,
so I might still
graze the apple,
but I wouldn't hit
the apple dead center.
So if I knew that the
apple wasn't going to drop
and I wanted to
hit it dead center,
I would have to choose some
different angle, theta 0.
We can sort of see intuitively
that that angle would
have to be a little bit steeper
so that the bullet would drop
and then hit the apple.
And so the way we
would solve that is
in our original
kinematic equations.
For the motion of the
apple, x would still
be a constant, d, but
if the apple wasn't
dropping then y of the apple
would also be a constant.
We wouldn't have the second
term, we would just have y
equals h.
And then I would have to
solve for a collision.
The other case to
think about, that I'd
like you to think about,
is what if the apple
begins dropping for a short
interval before we fired.
So that at the time that
we fire our projectile,
the apple is already dropping.
Well that's equivalent
to saying that at time
equals 0, when I
fire, that the apple
has some initial
velocity, whatever
velocity it's picked
up by dropping
and whatever interval
it was dropping before.
So now, my kinematics
for my apple
in the vertical
direction, I would
have an additional term
here, a minus v0 t,
where v0 is that
initial velocity.
And that's a
different v0, I should
have used a different symbol.
It's a different v0 than
the v0 of the bullet,
but there would be an initial
velocity, falling velocity,
of the apple that
I'd have to consider.
So the particular details of
what's happening with the apple
change the kinematics,
and it's worth
thinking about how that
would change your answer.